y
[Música]
los talibanes refuerzan su dominio
territorial en afganistán y se acercan a
la capital los insurgentes estarían a
sólo 11 km de kabul y tienen el control
de 19 capitales de provincia el
presidente afgano anunció este sábado
que está llevando a cabo consultas para
prevenir la situación de violencia y
desplazamiento
las autoridades de nicaragua llenaron la
sede del periódico la prensa luego de
que este anuncio que no circulará más en
su edición impresa debido a la retención
de insumos por parte del gobierno el
diario más antiguo del país enfrenta
ahora una investigación por supuestos
delitos de lavado de dinero y
defraudación aduanera
con la firma de un memorando de
entendimiento iniciaron en mexico los
diálogos entre representantes del
gobierno de venezuela y la oposición el
proceso busca resolver la crisis
política económica y social del país
siete puntos como el fin de las
sanciones y unos comicios limpios
marcarán las nuevas conversaciones
feliz fin de semana y bienvenidos a una
nueva emisión de noticias en france 24
los saluda andrés meza muñoz iniciamos
en afganistán porque los talibanes se
acercan cada vez más a la capital afgana
según fuentes locales los insurgentes
estarían a sólo 11 km de kabul durante
las últimas horas capturaron se harán a
otra importante ciudad del país lo que
incrementa a 19 el número de capitales
bajo dominio de los rebeldes en los
últimos tres meses y medio este grupo
también ha logrado controlar 140 centros
de distrito y casi 10 cruces fronterizos
la mayor conquista territorial en dos
décadas de guerra en un breve discurso
el presidente ashraf ghaní anunció que
se encuentran en consultas con los
líderes locales y socios internacionales
para prevenir la violencia la
inestabilidad y el desplazamiento de los
afganos mientras tanto los países de
occidente continúan la evacuación de sus
ciudadanos del país
es muy grande vodafone es tan nuestro
querido país afganistán está en grave
peligro de inestabilidad debido a la
guerra que se nos ha impuesto soy
consciente de la situación en afganistán
ofrezco mi más sentido pésame a los
mártires de las fuerzas de seguridad y
civiles y deseó a los heridos una pronta
recuperación
nuestro esfuerzo es cuidar de nuestros
compatriotas que han sido desplazados
debido a la situación
agradezco la valentía de las fuerzas de
seguridad y de defensa afganas que
tienen un fuerte espíritu para defender
a su pueblo y a su país
network 1
y dejándoles agua tan de pop en la
situación actual la reintegración de las
fuerzas de seguridad y de defensa es
nuestra prioridad y se están tomando
serias medidas al respecto al counter
zhang placas wild la policía
nicaragüense allanó las oficinas de la
prensa el único diario nacional
independiente que quedaba en el país y
conocido por ser abiertamente crítico
con el gobierno ahora enfrenta a una
investigación por presunto lavado de
dinero y defraudación aduanera esto
ocurre un día después de que el
periódico anunciara que no circulará más
por la falta de papel necesario para la
impresión y retenido por el gobierno de
daniel ortega
se intensifica la represión del gobierno
nicaragüense contra la oposición este
viernes la policía allanó las oficinas
de la prensa un diario abiertamente
crítico con el gobierno de daniel ortega
y el más antiguo del país la policía
acusa a los dirigentes de la publicación
de fraude aduanero y lavado de dinero
pero para los periodistas estas
acusaciones son mentiras inventadas por
el gobierno bueno de todos sabemos que
este es una medida más del del régimen
contra los contra la prensa
independiente pues que quiere callar no
pues de cualquier forma pero nosotros
seguimos con esa vocación de continuar
informando pese a todo veto la
electricidad fue cortada internet
bloqueado y los servicios informáticos
paralizados es un golpe más para este
periódico después de que se viera
obligado el jueves a suspender su
edición impresa por la escasez de papel
dado que las importaciones de los
insumos para las impresiones están
retenidas por la aduana como lo denuncia
el medio de comunicación a menos de tres
meses de las elecciones en nicaragua
el presidente daniel ortega ha sido
acusado de censurar a sus opositores
mientras busca un cuarto mandato
consecutivo al menos 32 opositores han
sido detenidos o puestos bajo arresto
domiciliario
incluidos siete precandidatos
presidenciales sólo uno quedan ama ya no
hay eres apareció a besar a la prensa
que a
necesitamos otro gobierno y lecciones no
tenemos esperanzas porque esto ya está
sólo él
panamá varias ong registran la
desaparición de al menos 20 medios de
comunicación independientes desde que
ortega asumió el poder en 2007
después de dos intentos fallidos durante
los últimos cuatro años este viernes se
iniciaron en mexico las conversaciones
entre el gobierno y la oposición
venezolana ambas partes firmaron un
memorando de entendimiento que pone las
bases para el futuro diálogo entre los
puntos a tratar se encuentran un
cronograma electoral garantías para los
comicios y el fin de las sanciones
informe de rosa pérez más deuda
principio de entendimiento para un único
objetivo dar salida a la crisis de
venezuela este viernes arrancaron en
ciudad de mexico las conversaciones
entre gobierno y oposición venezolana
auspiciadas por noruega con el
acompañamiento de rusia y países bajos
vislumbramos
el trabajador ha de estar
en donde encontramos punto de
confluencia para garantizar el porvenir
y la felicidad del pueblo del resuelve
derechos políticos garantías y hoja de
ruta electoral fin de las sanciones
económicas respeto al estado
constitucional renuncia a la violencia
protección social y garantías de
verificación de lo acordado son los
siete puntos de un documento que busca
llegar a un acuerdo integral de
convivencia democrática todo bajo una
metodología basada en el principio que
nada está acordado hasta que todo lo
esté el acercamiento representa un gran
paso para ambos actores que no se
sentaban desde 2019 cuando fracasaron
las conversaciones en barbados
ha tenido que ceder parte de su
narrativa para lograr un punto medio de
inicio
teniendo la convicción de que el proceso
es más que necesario
no asistió al acto nicolás maduro ni
tampoco juan guaidó quien tras
proclamarse presidente interino del país
en 2019 fue reconocido por 60 países de
los que ahora quedan sólo 10 según el
winston center la unión europea se
desmarcó del reconocimiento agua ido a
principios de este año eeuu sigue
apoyando al líder opositor y bloquea la
economía petrolera del país a través de
sanciones que tanto gobierno como
oposición coinciden en que deben ser
levantadas la administración de joe
biden se ha mostrado dispuesta a revisar
su política si hay avances
significativos en estos diálogos
el pasado mes de julio fue el mes más
caluroso registrado en el planeta en 142
años desde que comenzaron a hacerse los
registros según autoridades
meteorológicas de eeuu para los expertos
este nuevo récord se suma al perturbador
camino que el cambio climático ha
establecido para el mundo y que ha
traído consigo sequías e incendios
forestales precisamente en eeuu la ola
de calor no da tregua a altas
temperaturas se reportaron desde
portland hasta nueva york mientras el
fuego sigue consumiendo miles de
hectáreas en el sureste del país veamos
el informe de roxana baspineiro
un verano como ningún otro es el que
está viviendo eeuu debido a las altas
temperaturas y un sol abrasador que
azota al país de costa a costa
temperaturas de hasta 38.8 grados han
obligado a negocios de portland oregón a
cerrar sus puertas tanto para proteger a
los empleados como para desalentar que
los ciudadanos salgan a las calles y
banamex civil queremos asegurarnos de
cuidar bien nuestros empleos y nuestra
comunidad y simplemente tratar de
mantener a todos lo más seguros posible
durante la ola de calor la gobernadora
que el brawn declaró el estado de
emergencia hasta ahora la red eléctrica
del estado ha soportado el choque sin
embargo han solicitado a la ciudadanía
reducir el consumo eléctrico en los
momentos más calurosos del día la
situación ha llevado a algunos
ciudadanos a repartir botellas de agua y
alimentos a personas vulnerables o sin
hogar tienen corazones de oro y creo que
debería haber más gente hacia los
efectos de la ola de calor se viven
incluso en la costa este temperaturas
similares se observaron en los estados
de nueva jersey nueva york donde también
temen fallos en la red debido al elevado
uso de aparatos de aire acondicionado el
país continúa luchando con múltiples
focos de incendios según expertos
avivado por el calentamiento global
pixie en california es el segundo más
grande en la historia del estado
y antes de despedirnos los invitamos a
visitar nuestra página web www france24
puntocom en portada los detalles del
inicio de un nuevo diálogo entre el
gobierno y la oposición venezolana y
también la polémica en argentina por la
celebración del cumpleaños del
presidente en medio de las restricciones
hasta aquí este informativo en france 24
los invitamos a que continúen con toda
nuestra programación
[Música]